[Music]
we need to be the change we wish to see
even if it might seem strange initially
[Music]
a freshening head and has a plan in the
side a new direction
[Music]
start with us persons
[Music]
[Music]
enjoy
let's make it smart
[Music]
karma and joy
change let's make it Sparkle and ten
straight awesome displays open your
heart up and
let's create good karma
[Music]
change difference
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
[Music]
love it love it love it yeah now Maura
what's up guys thanks for coming on a
simulation whoa
super excited to be hosting you I'm
super grateful that we met at the Andrew
yang event in San Francisco and that we
scheduled this love the music now more
that was generate positive change such a
beautiful song we have so much to unpack
about the mission and about the actual
music the lyrics why you guys are
choosing us why you guys are putting
this together as an introduction
nollamara aka the peace and love party
band I love that and love that so so
much also one of the main missions is to
nourish positive human evolution and
have a lot of fun while we do it
and playing currently around the bay as
well as looking to be booked around the
USA as well all these links are below
let's have an introduction we have Neal
Nyberg first Neal is on the guitar he's
also on the vocals we have Coco Harlan
Coco Harlan is on the guitar and he's
also placed piano as well
we have know Mansfield who is on the
bass and we have young son who is on the
drums love it love it so this is the
four-piece band so let's start off by
asking you guys you know that was
beautiful that was generate positive
change teach us about that song teach us
about the mission teach us about the
vision that you guys have and we'll pass
around the mic as you guys thank you yes
we all want world peace but we don't
just want world peace we want to thrive
and so we want to inspire people to
create a better world and as our mission
and we we're not just a fun band like
we're actually trying to make it impact
in the world because that matters and so
this is why we're doing it and we're
gonna have a whole lot of fun while
doing it too because we're a party band
too
that's that's beautiful just once the
World Peace is such a crucial pillar of
ours as well and we can absolutely get
there and do it and have a lot of fun
while doing it I know maybe he basically
covers everything that we need to say
everyone should just love each other by
our new album because we have secret
messaging on it it's gonna make you all
love each other I just want to say
playing with this band gets me in this
great positive attitude and I think if
you just go around each day you just put
a smile on your face maybe you're not
feeling so good just have a good just a
good attitude and be considerate you can
get a lot very far and it's gonna affect
everyone in a positive way it's really
very simple
butterfly effect with the positive vibes
that we put out every single moment of
life grateful for life now okay so
that's on the on the mission on the
vision love it and gonna be playing this
beautiful music and having a blast while
doing it
now how did the band get together how
did you four end up finding well I
originally started the band in 2007 in a
garage in Newark California which is in
the southeast Bay and and there's a
couple different incarnations of the
band over the years and for about six
years I didn't do anything and then when
I met Coco in early 2017 we restarted
the band and eventually we everybody and
we've been playing around in San
Francisco for the last two years and
constantly evolving and growing and
playing bigger and bigger shows and now
we get to do this with you guys find no
and young-sun how'd you go how did you
two guys get found well we all belong to
the vampire Club of San Francisco so
that's how we got to know each other
I could say more about the vampire Club
and the meeting secret meeting places on
Monday nights at the Hotel Utah open mic
with Brendon get sell I met all these
guys through that and through it an open
mic that I used to host with my wife
went over q and so I think it's just a
music community people will always be
playing playing in different bands and
now we're we just formed this little
tribe here so it's a growing scene love
it okay so that's how the band got
together so it's been two years now of
performing together okay so now and able
to book able to book them so links are
in the bio for those that are interested
book them and now okay so now you guys
gave us this this big picture what you
want to see the world to get to we're
100% on board what about we like asking
about the current state of humanity what
is your current take on the state of
humanity humanity is growing and
maturing right now consciousness is
rising on the planet we're going through
a major transformation as a planet right
now and people are starting to become
more aware of things in general things
are starting to become more ethical
we're going in that direction and we
want to continue with the progression
and the advancement of humanity along
with its maturity humanity needs to
mature a little bit more and become more
loving to each other more forgiving
because being more loving and being more
forgiving that's going to breed more
unity and more unity is going to breed
more cooperation and the more
cooperation we have is the more positive
change we're gonna have and then the
more positive change we're gonna have is
a thriving planet for all life and then
we all [ __ ] win and that will that
would be great for everybody just party
so it's a it's an it's a slow period of
a consciousness increasing and us
figuring out how to play together on
this beautiful playground we have on
earth figure out how to max
our resource flows to enable everyone to
be the absolute peak of their creative
potential okay and then now on the last
song generate positive change tell us
about some of those lyrics we need to be
the change that we want to see we can do
it we need to think globally act locally
teach us about these lyrics yeah I use
them I use some cliches like we want to
be the change we want to see and think
globally and act locally which is very
true and everybody should do that we we
just want to see everything become
better on this planet we want to make
this planet shiny and sparkly and
vibrance and just happy for all life we
want everybody to be supported we're all
each other's allies and so people need
to realize that that we're all just
little organisms on this floating rock
out in space I mean to get along and
work together so we can all thrive I
like the song a lot I love it
I really appreciate that that
perspective of being just you know 8
billion human organisms on the rock
along with all of the other plants
animals insects and although on just
this oneness that we really need to
start embodying and feeling it dosing up
on let's roll into the second song mama
bear and then we'll break it down
afterwards let's do it
mother of all creation one two three
four
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
love it love it the crowd goes wild so
this is so interesting since both on the
beautiful loving nurturing spirit and
energy of a mother of the child that is
that is therefore at the same time it's
this mother earth it's his mother
evolution and so yeah just love it love
so now now tell us a pact this I know
you said at the beginning we want to
hear more on the importance of mama bear
yeah well I have a have a close personal
friend of mine who's also a second mom
to me and so I call her mama bear and
that's how the title came to be and then
I wrote it about all the great mother
figures and I know it's highly relatable
cuz everybody can everybody has a great
mother figure in their lives it doesn't
have to be a mom it could be a
grandmother it could be an aunt it could
be it could be a bigger older sister and
it could also be just about about the
earth the earth you know mother earth
and mother the molta the multi-verse
which was the one that we're all part of
source energy the divine mother of all
creation and I just wanted to honor all
those all those mother figures and that
that we like we like it to talk about
this a lot on the show the importance of
like this the seed that is birthed into
the world right is the child and then
that given the right nutrients given the
right care love compassion water food
shelter energy all of the basic needs
air that it needs that that that seed
can more easily thrive when it gets
exposed to all of the potential creative
stimuli that that it can actualize
itself with and one of those things is
this central key point of this love and
compassion of a mother a father
grandmother on like you said all of the
different friend at the same time
we talk about source right this infinite
consciousness the source consciousness
this mother energy that we're all baked
into this interconnectedness that is so
beautiful okay so now I want to I want
to ask about like we have you know we
have this benevolent [ __ ] rules over
here we love that so much
we talked about nourishing positive
human evolution your messaging is very
profound now what you know we talked
earlier at the beginning about what we
have for a long term vision of world
peace we talked about what's happening
on the earth today tell us about these
incremental steps towards love towards
unity what can we do today with this
positive energy that we can carry around
with us what are the things we can do
today to continue pushing this forward
in our communities and around the world
I'm really not sure what to say I think
Neil's usually the spokesperson of the
band and I just rely on him to cover
everything so yeah I've always just been
about trying to get everyone to to just
work together there's so much stuff on
the news about the enemies and like
they're making up enemies for everybody
like and it's just false the [ __ ] are
they were the enemies that's the bottom
line right there there's no enemies
the powers that be have used divide and
conquer to rule over people for
thousands of years and it's been working
and now we're trying to unring that Bell
we're trying to undo that we're trying
to remove all these barriers that divide
us because they've been set up to
control us and to keep us down and
really the people have the power and
people need to be empowered and know in
order to work together people need to be
more loving to one another and forgive
one another
and and none of us are religious at all
but we want people to be more loving and
more forgiving because that will that
matters and that will make an impact in
the world everybody should do mushrooms
and be kind to each other absolutely I
totally agree yeah you know I just want
to say I mean about just about this
entire thing you know our planet is the
mother you know without it there's no
we're not gonna do anything we wouldn't
be here without it and I think we just
have to be more kind to it and be
careful about what we do and realize
that we're I feel like honestly I feel
like the human species is sort of it's
sort of a pest and that we need to learn
how to be better you know I think we're
making a huge impact on the world right
now and it's not good and I feel like
things aren't doing well but you know
we're just a band you know but we can I
feel like this is one little tiny
message toward that you know we're just
trying to get people in a good mood so
they can be more receptive to this you
know and not be fighting each other so I
think that's that's that's the first
step it's really up to everyone your
impact goes a long way even you know as
a band as the as the for you are goes a
long way as we keep spreading these
messages further and further across the
world the good ideas will spread on and
we'll get to that love and unity I want
to ask you there is a certain like
complexity to how all of these different
evolution the evolution of all these
different cultures and tribes kind of
grew up and it's hard to get people to
wrap their mind around the tribe of
earth the tribe of that you have that
won that Union versus the tribe of the
individual countries or the individual
nuclear families how do we get more
people to get past that and especially
in the complexities with trade and
economics and and the and the in and all
of the the cyber war that's happening
with information technology how do we
get what needs to happen for that
spiritual awakening to get past the
tribes and into the into the oneness
into the unity be kind to each other
no I mean that's the thing everybody's
needs to be mellow I wouldn't be kind
and that's kind of what we're talking
about and like we're we're kind of
opening but as far as a band you know
like we're actually happy and like each
other in shouldn't and Neil writes these
really cool songs with like mama bear I
mean we all love to party with our moms
you know yeah yeah I mean we're see see
how [ __ ] wholesome we are no but
anyway yeah that's that's we everybody
should be try to be go out of their way
to be kind I know all circumstances we
we we want to make it really popular for
people to be more kind to one another
make it like the thing to do it's like
everybody's doing it like we're all want
to be more loving to one another and if
you know it catches on like if it's the
thing to do with like everybody's doing
it then more people are gonna do it and
so us getting out there more and getting
our music out there can help inspire
that because because we don't have all
the answers and no one person has all
the answers
we want to inspire humans to figure all
this stuff out and and and work together
so it's an interesting you know no keep
saying like do mushrooms
you know psychedelics are something that
but we we we we are totally on board you
know we love maps we've had
multidisciplinary Association for
psychedelic studies on our show many
times and we we are totally for the use
responsible use of psychedelics
especially for spiritual awakening that
it meditation helps with spiritual
awakening
these things are deeply important to get
more people practicing and involved with
and awakening through that so completely
agree and even just the general acts of
kindness of you know thinking your
parents for bringing into our thinking
the communities that you have for food
and electricity all the people that
built all the things that we use every
every single day ok next up we have have
a beer is our next song or third song
yes yes whoo so let's uh yeah let's jump
into have a beer and you guys will rock
that one out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
enjoy again this kind of plays on the
you know doing a little bit of our
favorite you know psychedelics or you
know alcohol whatever it may be
responsibly like you responsibly not to
the point of actually harming ourselves
with the consumption of of this and you
know taking uber if we're driving all
these kinds of things that you mentioned
the song yes yes but it brings us
together there's an aspect of the
community that we can have when we when
we sit down and we use these these times
to bring us together and to and maybe
have you know good conversations and and
unpack some of the things that we have
going on in the world now another thing
that this that this really brought forth
for me was this idea of you know the
power of music for change it's almost as
though you know music is something
that's so evolutionarily old right our
our audio right our ability to hear and
so tell us about you know the your you
know you under your understanding of how
music and like your and your songs can
get people into this you know this
rhythm of wanting to follow the steps
towards that world peace to that unity
so tell us about that we're the peace
and love party band that's our nickname
so we we think that partying you know
can bring people together music brings
people together but also having a beer
with each other you know that can build
you can meet people that way build
community and it people in having a good
time in a good atmosphere that that that
is good for unity we like beer would
like like that guy be and we're we are
but we aren't running for Supreme Court
but no beer
is okay anything is okay if if you don't
abuse it
you know like beer is cool cuz it'll
make you loosen and dance better at
least you think you're dancing better
and so but yeah if any minute an
asteroids gonna hit so we might as well
be partying right now
yes well yeah I mean let's have a beer
you know the song used to be called chug
a beer and so you know we were thinking
about it and we're like how about have a
beer a little more responsible with it
you know chugging a beer that might lead
to some some bad stuff going on so I
think it might be sip of beer at one
point we'll see what happens changing it
to have a tea can bond over tea yeah
that's funny I'm sorry it's like that
that highlights the evolution of the of
the ethics as well as that we may start
with thinking chug but then we take it
back a notch for safety and for health
and all that stuff I love love love the
power of music and the power of your
music of now Moore's music in order to
be able to get us towards that unity
towards that world peace and I think to
have more Millennials and Gen Z the
young people listening to this music
making their own bands that propagate
music of love and peace and unity is
definitely what we need because music is
that powerful changer so you know in the
video as well as well you know what we
try and do these video these
thought-provoking conversations we think
are very good very compatible ways that
get people excited okay we have some we
have some questions that we like to ask
on the show all right and and um even
you know you explained this earlier Neil
and I want to make sure people hear this
message again um
teach them about how that unity gets us
to greater cooperation which gives us
the greater change and gets us to that
that state of planetary like I said none
of us are religious but we take the
things from Christianity and
most other like like most major world
religions teach love and and and the
golden rule which is just doing to
others what you would have them do unto
you and being more loving and being more
forgiving to each other
well breed more unity that way because
people are become friends that they
support each other and then more unity
then there's more cooperation and people
need to work together and then more
cooperation then there's more positive
change and then more and more and more
positive change a thriving planet for
all life nice and bright and shiny and
sparkly and thriving and and then we all
win and that's the end game there's this
there's this this is this first step
like you guys have all been saying now
is this this loving and forgiving
attitude towards each other and towards
what we have here on earth and there's
there's a mmm I kind of hinted at this
earlier there's these weird economic and
political and social pressures that kind
of are driving people into this me
mentality me I reap III me and it's kind
of plague because there's no there's no
there's no separation there's no the ego
is an illusion right and so to get to
that state of interconnectedness is this
really deep process of like sincere self
work and I think that's something that
you know we've had Bernard Gunter on the
show we heavily agree like this process
of tuning in word and working on one's
own self towards that love and
forgiveness can then catalyze a massive
global shift in that direction that the
systems have to change to the economics
the politics have to change in that
direction as well okay the couple
questions that we like to ask on
simulation on the way out will go maybe
from Neil over here and the first
question is do you believe we are alone
in the cosmos oh absolutely not
we were definitely not alone the
universe is teeming with life I I'm not
really talking about aliens right now in
my career
but I but yes I definitely know that
they exist yes in the future for sure
yeah I don't think that we're alone we
might not have found anything out there
right now but we can't be alone I was
alone a little while yesterday but it
didn't last
that's no we're not alone do you know
that a scientist told me once that
there's a gene in your DNA from
everything that's ever lived before you
like so it just reinforces that we're
all one I mean there's Frog genes in you
and there's tree genes and me and
there's trilobite genes and yeah mostly
trilobite
no but yeah it's we're definitely not
only are there others
everywhere else we're all connected here
and there you know anyway well just
think about all the different species on
this planet and how different they are
from you know the extremophiles
at the bottom of the ocean in sexed
humans everything in between and imagine
just imagine what there could be out
there now there's no evidence that
there's anything out there but I mean
look at at the known universe it's a
gigantic with so many different types of
planets and areas that I mean there it's
it's unimaginable what could be out
there so that's what I that's that's
that brings up my Korea tivity it makes
me want to just create what that could
be and not be anywhere close and then
let's ask this is simulation so we will
ask you are we in a simulation
well they say life is a dream so I don't
know
it could be I know that that the
universe is holographic and that
everything is energy vibrating at a
certain frequency and I know that the
frequencies are rising on the planet
right now
that's all I really could say about it
being a simulation I think that it's
possible that it could be a simulation
but it doesn't change anything we should
make the best of it I was in a
simulation yesterday but then the dog
came in and puked on the floor and I
just split took away you know ruin the
mood I don't think we there's no there's
no way to know it's really no way to
know so it's a fun thought it's a
thought experiment hopefully we'll be
pro 'king poking the simulation with our
scientific probe soon and yeah and
checking yeah some way to test it
exactly exactly and then our last
question on the show is what is the most
beautiful thing in the world love is the
most beautiful thing in the world
love is the cure love is the universal
key all humans are here to learn how to
love and each lifetime is a learning and
growing experience and you'll go through
lessons and struggles and it's all
really basically to learn how to be more
loving and yep I think that covers it
love is the most beautiful thing in the
world except for my sister the most
beautiful thing in the world to me is
right here on my drum set you can see it
and that would be my wife gonna freak
you know big [ __ ] deal can I do it
over my wife bundles
music we can't forget music quick edit
yeah I need to edit edit I love it okay
so give us the quick bit on the future
of nollamara you guys have to a Bay Area
performing links are below everyone also
I'm looking to get booked for you know
you said and have a beer you said that
you're looking for again sponsors for
the songs are you guys thinking about
doing you know other music around our
interconnectedness and our unity is that
kind of the trajectory of the music as
well so teach us about the future for
you guys yeah we're just or just wait
until someone wants to sponsor us so we
can tour and spread our magic and love
around the world we we set up shows
around San Francisco and the Bay Area
we're playing at bottom of the hill
tomorrow night here in San Francisco
we're also I'm hosting a free outdoor
indie music festival on Ocean Beach
Saturday June 22nd it's called June
Beach Fest and we are playing and Coco
has his own band no parking there
playing and no has his own band
revolution which are playing and yeah
we're we're all in each other's bands
really and we're playing it a few
different house parties and we're
working on our next album which is our
party album called getting down hella
tough and we're also about to release a
really important song called Solar Punk
opus which is all about creating new
green sustainable infrastructure all
over the world being very ethical very
green sustainable Fairtrade ethically
sourced everything
a really egalitarian societies we want
to promote people to live in that way we
basically we want to raise money to
build universal basic infrastructure all
over the world and especially in the
poorest areas of the world so clean
water housing stuff like that and that's
our plan for the future no give me give
me the quick bit on on the other the
other bands this is interesting we
didn't know that so our young son also
in another band as well
okay so teach us you have we have no
parking was to teach us about the other
band as well and about what is the theat
is the mission in the vision of your
other of your other bands as well well
my mission I just really left playing
music that's all I want to do I listen
to Stevie Ray Vaughan's guitar playing
and I try to pick up all the little
things he's doing Jimi Hendrix and
that's all I do I just want to play
that's I don't have any like specific
mission I just want to do what I love to
do that's when you know that someone's
super dedicated at their craft is that
they just want to do that that's like
the thing that they do with their life
love it yeah I
it's I feel really lucky because I'm
sort of in a community and this group in
particular but other ones that we're all
connected with Jason's man Jason plays
and
these guys play yeah
the San Francisco music community is
probably one of the tightest that I've
ever been around
and it's and it's really based on sort
of supporting each other as opposed to
maybe Los Angeles or New York so that's
it everyone thanks for tuning into the
episode with featuring Nala Mora on
generating positive change in their band
and everything check out all their links
in the bio keep supporting the artists
and entrepreneurs that you believe in
everyone much love and we will see you
soon we're gonna close with California
Poppy or his last song very much
[Music]
we're than a dozen bouquets of tumors
I'm so glad I met you
thanks to keep
ocean breeze in the tropics across the
calm open the cities I like to cheer the
type a gallon
[Music]
you massage my brains pleasure receptors
that babe when were together lights
taste better than ever
[Music]
and surely you love me way better than
anybody
I feel plenty lucky even when you gently
touch me we've had many sunny days
together
[Music]
[Music]
thank you so much
[Applause]